Inside the second van.
Get that notebook out, babe.
Are you paying attention?
I'm paying attention.
We just made it to van three.
By the way, van two was amazing.
I really want it; Dana's not so sure.
I like it.
I just, it makes me nervous to buy something that somebody doesn't want to part with.
That's the issue,...
...but I think if we can figure out a date to purchase the van, and she agrees on it, then…
We'll do a full VO tonight explaining the whole van situation.
It's a dilemma.
So the dilemma is this:...
The seller of the van doesn't want to part with it for three months...
...because she wants to use it one last time for her vacation at the end of September.
But obviously, we want the van as soon as possible,...
...so we don't have to build it out in the winter in Berlin.
Yeah.